[Music]
everyone welcome to another edition of
behind the hustle I'm back with Zack
Crockett our Sunday editor Zack good to
see you
hey man good to be back for another
episode of slurs in their closets during
honking is that where you are you're
literally stuck in your closet it's the
only quiet place I'm fine so let's go
making doing these times I had this
image of you I always thought you lived
out in the woods like so you go for
these runs on these trails or on your
house and I just had this picture of you
secluded off somewhere quiet but it's
not that I guess huh yeah it's uh every
place has its ups and downs right now
sir all right well at least you found
somewhere quiet I doubt my place is
gonna be quiet so forgive any
interruptions that happen here this week
you're doing a piece that's near and
dear to my heart I love to bake bread
I've done it for many years my kids eat
like a loaf of bread a day my wife
thankfully has taken up the habit of
making a loaf of bread every day for us
she won't make more than one because
it's like about what one is just enough
but it it's almost impossible to find
flour now people are crazy and mad and
excited to do this and it's almost like
we've returned to this agrarian culture
what what's your story gonna be about
what are you sort of how are you
approaching this yeah this week we're
doing a story on the meteoric rise of at
home bread baking so as you said it's
pretty much impossible to find flour
yeast bread starter even bread machines
bread pans the entire bread economy has
been shaken to its core by this influx
of quarantined people looking for a new
hobby
so we're diving into this some of the
numbers behind that using tools like
Jungle Scout look at increases in Amazon
searches and sales volume of things like
yeast
you know just utilizing basic tools like
Google Trends we talked to red star
yeast and King Arthur Flour which are
some of the oldest brands in the country
which are both facing immense shortages
right now and supply chain issues and we
also ran a survey and heard from almost
a thousand hustle readers war stories in
the kitchen a lot of gummy sourdough
lows and also a lot of bread experts who
have a lot of experience baking very
cool so one of the things we found was
about the sort of reimagine some some of
these bread making machines that had not
been selling very well and what what did
you what was interesting about that so
the the bread making machine was this
thing that was rolled out in 1983 1984
it was marketed to be the next toaster
and for a while it did really well about
three or four or five million American
households bought this bread making
machine and then it kind of just died
out it disappeared and it's hasn't
really sold well in the last few decades
right now during coronavirus Cuisinart
bread makers are just exploding in sales
if you if you go on Amazon it's like one
of the top selling products in the bread
category and so you know one thing we've
been looking into is how this pandemic
has affected industries you might not
normally think about I think at this
point it's pretty obvious to everyone
that there's this huge explosion in
bread interests the things you don't
really think about are like these you
know the resurgence of these old weird
machines like bread machines it's it's
been kind of interesting to watch that
happen so you also talked to this little
bakery called mr. Holmes bake house and
interestingly I've when I was out in San
Francisco I'm based in the DC area
I flew out to San Francisco probably 15
times last year and worked out of the
office there where our headquarters is
and every time I leave San Francisco I
walk across the financial district down
to the Ferry Building and I buy like a
bunch of loaves of sourdough for my kids
because they're crazy about it I didn't
even know about mr. Holmes but mr.
Holmes has had an interesting pivot in
this time with obviously not being able
to have a storefront yeah has gotten
really creative and bakeries all over
the place are closed and his solution
gives he had no ecommerce experience
really is an entrepreneur at heart a
true hustler kind of guy he decided to
start selling bread starter kits online
so he leveraged his expertise and in
baking took his team which is full of
skilled bakers and all kinds of culinary
artisans and basically used his
warehouse transformers warehouse into
kind of an ad hoc ecommerce operation
where he's shipping out hundreds of
these breasts armor kits you can buy
them for like 25 bucks they come with
everything you need and the average you
know bread novice like me can cook a
loaf in a few tit bake a loaf in a few
days so it's really kind of a genius
idea and we're starting to see this
adopted by a number of other small
bakeries around the country number of
people in our survey said they were
doing similar things bakeries are
selling loaves through Instagram and
they're finding all kinds of creative
ways to keep themselves afloat during
this during these shoppings here so do
they sell a sourdough starter or is it
just a starter kit all right so the one
I bought is just like a white bread
starter there is a way to convert it
into a sourdough starter kit I think but
he's also rolling out he isn't a cookie
baking kit that he's selling now he's
kind of expanding into some
is but it's it's like an immensely
popular bakery their stuff is incredible
if you've ever been in San Francisco and
hopefully in the future if you have a
chance to try them out they're really
great so they already had this like cult
following both at the retail location
and on Instagram online so they were
able to tap into that bit very cool so
you as a novice Baker you said the word
novice have you actually tried to bake
some bread this week yourself
I'm a terrible baker but uh we we bought
a kit for mr. Holmes last week and it's
on day two of feeding right now so you
have to feed it for a few days he feed
it flour and water or let it incubate
right now he's sitting in the
refrigerator and gonna try baking him
tonight his name is pure pot my name did
appear fine so we'll see how it turns
out well that's good I I'm looking
forward to reading your story Zach and I
think it'll be a lot of fun to see sort
of a your take on the economics of the
bread baking phenomenon that we're going
through right now so thanks for joining
us again this week Zach
[Music]